bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP dans
savouregarde ce soir arrow sur les
squatteurs la proposition de loi contre
les squats et les loyers impayés durci
les sanctions pour protéger les
propriétaires alors mesurent légitimes
ou précarisation accrues des mals logés
on en débat dans un instant sur ce
plateau comment expliquer la guerre de
Poutine nos deux grands témoins ce soir
ce sont plongés dans le parcours du
dictateur russe KGB mafia idéologie et
immense soif de revanche sur le passé
soviétique les historiens Stéphane
Courtois et Gallia Karman ont dirigé Le
livre noir de Vladimir Poutine chez
Robert Laffont ils seront avec nous dans
la deuxième partie enfin nos affranchis
ce soir vu du perchoir avec les amants
d'un Gava sur ses députés exténués qui
plongent sur un nouveau rythme de
travail le baromètre doxa de Céline
braque qui s'est penché ce mois-ci sur
la droite à la veille du congrès des
républicains et puis le parti pris de
l'écho de Fanny guinochet sur l'annonce
choc d'Emmanuel Macron d'étendre les aux
grandes métropoles coûte comme ou kozz
génie voilà pour le menu ce sport est
parti
[Musique]
droit au logement contre droit de
propriété la proposition doit
anti-squate de la majorité n'en finit
pas de diviser dans l'émission on va le
voir dans un instant alors loi équilibré
ou loi anti pauvre bonsoir mode Braison
bonsoir et merci d'être là ce soir vous
êtes député Renaissance le parti
présidentiel député des Hauts-de-Seine
bonsoir Aurélien tachées bienvenue
députérope Écologie Les Verts du
Val-d'Oise et membre de la nuque bonsoir
Jean-Baptiste Hérault ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes le
porte-parole de l'association Droit au
logement enfin Jean pinsol le président
de la Chambre des propriétaires du Grand
Paris va nous rejoindre dans un tout
petit instant le temps pour Stéphane
blackovski de nous planter le décor si
j'ai bien compris le droit au logement
aurait-il pris l'ascendant sur tous les
autres droits le biais de la côte tout
de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes
bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien compris ce
soir alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam
l'an dernier il y a eu 170 de bandes
d'expulsion contre des squatteurs
demandés déposés pardon préfecture alors
170 finalement c'est pas énorme non ça
fait deux par jour sauf que si tous les
deux jours on lit dans le journal qu'il
y a une maison qui a été squattée bah là
ça commence à faire beaucoup en tout cas
c'est la vie de Pierre midi qui débute
il suffit d'ouvrir le journal tous les
jours pour voir que nos concitoyens sont
trop nombreux à être victimes de squats
et d'arnaqueurs qui sont sous le vent
multirécidivistes alors évidemment
présenté comme ça on a l'impression Paul
me dit tout à fait c'est pas tout à fait
pareil en revanche est-ce que cette loi
elle est écrite sous la pression des
médias ça ça donne un petit peu cette
impression là quand même rappeler malgré
ce côté pression médiatique que
aujourd'hui un propriétaire qui
changerait la serrure de son maison sa
maison parce qu'elle est squattée risque
des sanctions plus importantes que le
squatteur lui-même donc du point de vue
du rapporteur de la loi Guillaume
kasbarian il se dit là il y a un moment
où les profitent les parents les
propriétaires sont tellement méfiants à
l'idée de louer qu'il faut les rassurer
donc c'est ça son idée on écoute
si nous avons un marché locatif
tellement engorgé par des demandes dans
tous les sens par des certificats des
garanties des cautions des attestations
des justificatifs c'est qu'il n'y a pas
assez de confiance entre les bailleurs
et les locataires si nous réussissons à
rétablir cette confiance il deviendra
vite possible de diminuer les exigences
des bailleurs donc l'idée de la majorité
pour rassurer les propriétaires c'est de
sanctionner plus durement l'équateur
bien sûr ou les locataires qui auraient
de très gros impayés en triplant les
sanctions qui sont prévues contre eux
alors quand la majorité veut rassurer
les propriétaires et bien c'est la
gauche elle qui s'inquiète oui
exactement ils reprennent ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure est-ce que ça
serait pas tout ça simplement pour
répondre à quelques faits divers qui ont
d'ailleurs scandalisé tout le monde mais
qui nécessite peut-être pas une loi en
tout cas une motion de rejet comme
d'habitude de la part Delphi elle est
finie
comme d'habitude et puis ça a quand même
donner l'occasion donc un député qui est
un ancien du droit au logement bah de
dire rappeler la position de des
insoumis à ce sujet elle citer un député
que les Français fonctionne bien en
rigouest plus que tenu sous le nom de
l'Abbé Pierre
en introduisant le fait qu'occuper tout
type de logements vacances apparente à
un vol avec trois ans à 15 ans de prison
ferme vous glissez monsieur le
rapporteur sur une pente dangereuse qui
n'est pas contrairement à ce que vous
avancez la protection des petits
propriétaires mais la criminalisation de
tous les mal logés autrement dit
si votre loi était passée jadis l'abbé
Pierre serait en prison vous allez voir
que la référence à la baie pierre qui
était assez bien vu finalement pour
conclure ce discours là on n'a pas
vraiment ému le garde des sceaux et
Dupont-Moretti non franchement lui il
est très terre à terre on l'écoute
maintenant la grandeur d'âme l'abbé
Pierre qui devient votre référence moi
j'aimerais bien voir moi si on venait
investir votre domicile vous voyez que
vous rentriez chez vous qu'avec votre
clé vous ne puissiez plus rentrer on
vous entendrez bon oui ça a l'impression
de pas tellement la des pères il balance
ça n'a rien vers demain le garde des
sceaux enfin la bière n'est plus là et à
soi-même depuis 2007 mais il y a une
fondation qui poursuit son action et la
présidente de cette association de la
fondation de l'abbé Pierre elle elle est
remontée contre ses poils scandaleuse
je crois très important de conserver
tous les efforts faits dans la
prévention des expulsions locatives il
faut laisser le temps du travail social
il faut laisser au juge le pouvoir
d'analyser chaque situation d'être au
plus proche des réalités difficiles
d'une expulsion qui est toujours un
échec vous doutez bien les arguments
n'ont pas convaincu tout le monde
notamment parce que les communistes eux
rappelle que quand on vous dit ils vont
défendre les petits propriétaires en
fait en France il y a 10% des Français
qui possèdent trois logements trois
logements plus donc c'est vraiment une
petite minorité et c'est 10% de français
il possède un seul quasiment 46%
quasiment 50% des logements donc cette
aide pour les petits propriétaires en
difficulté est-ce que ça va pas surtout
aider les gros l'inquiétude de Stéphane
peu
vous êtes un train de faire une loi
déséquilibrée qui va aller à l'encontre
des locataires et des et des personnes
en difficulté de logement pour protéger
des propriétaires pas les petits
propriétaires dont vous parlez mais
surtout les multiples propriétaires qui
font une rente de l'immobilier de
l'augmentation des loyers ben voilà on
se rend bien compte que l'équilibre
entre défense des propriétaires et des
locataires et compliqués à trouver
Stéphane pour ce billet complet et
piquant comme chaque soir Maud Brejon je
commence avec vous c'est vrai quand on
regarde avant de rentrer dans le détail
des des articles ne serait-ce que
l'intitulé de la loi vous englobez la
lutte contre les squatteurs et la lutte
contre les impayés des locataires est-ce
que vous n'amagez pas La
Malga mais pas je vais y arriver de
situation clairement différentes c'est
une loi portée par Guillaume caisse
barian qui est à la fois courageux et
équilibrée on a mal gamme pas on cible
les comportements malhonnêtes et c'est
vraiment là dessus qu'il faut insister
ce n'est pas les propriétaires contre
les locataires c'est pas les personnes
aisées contre les personnes précaires
loin de là d'ailleurs une collègue a eu
l'occasion de rappeler dans l'hémicycle
ce qui avait été fait pour le droit au
logement depuis cinq ans c'est pas une
loi en France des comportements qui sont
profondément malhonnêtes les squats en
premier lieu chacun comprend que
lorsqu'on rentre chez soi le soir et que
quelqu'un s'est installé chez vous vous
pouvez plus rentrer pendant un an ou
deux ans trois ans c'est absolument
délinquant
par définition selon le terme c'est des
délinquants et puis des gens qui ne
payent pas leur loyer sur des longues
durées alors il y a bien sûr dans un
premier temps il faut les aider mais
situation qu'on peut pas accepter sur la
durée il y a pas d'un côté des gentils
locataires et de l'autre côté des
méchants
et surtout je ne veux pas on n'est pas
là opposés les gens entre eux il y a pas
de raison de poser les locataires aux
propriétaires en France d'ailleurs je
tiens à le rappeler c'est pas une
insulte que d'être propriétaire il y a
beaucoup de Françaises et de Français
qui ont acheté une petite maison qu'on a
acheté un appartement c'est loin d'être
des rentiers et donc il est tout à fait
normal qu'on protège la propriété privée
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire là
bon Aurélien taché c'est vrai que les
squatteurs c'est un délit est-ce que
est-ce que vous vous dites que malgré la
loi ils vont se mettre à l'abri mais il
faut être précis ce qui est un délice
c'est la violation de domicile et c'est
déjà puni par la loi il y a une peine de
prison personne ne s'y opposition
Jean-Baptiste terreau pose pas je m'y
oppose pas je ne suis pas vous ne vous
posez pas simplement vous avec cette
proposition de loi et c'est là que c'est
vraiment extrêmement dangereux et
d'ailleurs c'est par hasard si le
ministre les ministres défile depuis
tout à l'heure pour donner des avis
défavorables aux amendements et aux
articles de cette proposition de loi qui
vient rappelons-le du groupe à l'instant
Christophe plusieurs fois d'affilée il y
a des amendements du Gouvernement ou du
modèle qui ne sont pas repris par la
majorité macroniste c'est ça ce que vous
dites ce que je dis c'est le Ministre du
ministre de la transition écologique
vient pour dire que certains amours oui
voilà des amendements que tu es en
l'occurrence du MoDem mais contre la
proposition de loi de ce variant sont
quand même rejetées par Renaissance
pourquoi pourquoi
parce que non non mais tout simplement
pourquoi parce que là on parle pas de
quelqu'un qui rentre chez vous dans
votre domicile qui s'installe qui fait
changer les serrures et puis qui reste
là ces situations là elles sont très peu
nombreuses mais absolument choquantes et
il faut les traiter là ce que fait
monsieur casbiran c'est tout autre chose
et il l'a dit dans le discours que vous
avez montré tout à l'heure ce qu'il veut
c'est faciliter la location donc pour
faciliter la location monsieur se dit
Monsieur casse balance se dit qu'il faut
plus facilement donner à la possibilité
les propriétaires de mettre les
locataires dehors quel que soit leur
situation donc on assimile des gens qui
n'ont pas pu payer deux trois quatre
mois de loyer à des gens qui sont
rentrés par effraction dans un domicile
et qui aurait changé les serrures et on
ne fait pas que pour un logement parce
que la loi de Monsieur casse barrière le
fait aussi pour les immeubles pour les
immeubles vides vous savez il y a
quelques années moi je militaire pour le
droit au logement pas dans l'association
de Monsieur Hérault mais dans une autre
et bien il nous est arrivé d'aller dans
des immeubles dans le centre de Paris
qui était vide pour faire un espèce de
squat symbolique pour alerter sur le
fait qu'il y avait des sans-abris cette
époque là c'était il y a une petite
quinzaine d'années vers 2008-2009
monsieur Chirac il a répondu avec quoi
avec le droit au logement opposable
monsieur kasbarian et la majorité
Renaissance répond en envoyant les
locataires en prison
alors là locataire en prison est-ce que
c'est ce que vous voyez les choses comme
ça c'est ce qu'on pouvait lire sur vos
pancartes Jean-Baptiste terreau je
rappelle que vous campez enfin les temps
dure au logement sont sur la place
Édouard Herrero devant l'Assemblée
nationale depuis le début de ce débat
donc depuis lundi c'est ça qu'on peut
lire sur les pancartes la loi c'est la
prison ou crevé dans la rue est-ce que
c'est c'est aussi binaire que ça
bah écoutez oui d'abord
il faut être clair sur cette question du
squat ce qui amène enfin l'élément
nouveau du de cette proposition cette
criminalisé les squatteurs de logement
vides bon or on a 3,1 millions de
logements vacances selon l'INSEE en
France on en a jamais 2 millions de mal
logés on en a jamais compté autant on
était à 1,8 millions à la fin des années
90 on a un problème on a de plus en plus
de sans-abris et on a de plus en plus de
logements vides et comme disait l'abbé
Pierre est-ce qu'on peut criminaliser un
criminer un père de famille qui pour
protéger ses enfants va s'installer dans
un logement vide plutôt que de plutôt
que de rester dans la rue avant la loi
ne punissait pas l'occupation d'un
logement vide c'est ce que vient changer
la proposition de loi oui parce que
l'occupation de la résidence principale
de quelqu'un de sa résidence secondaire
ou de sa résidence
occasionnelle et
sanctionner donc pour la résidence
principale c'est un délit pour la
résidence occasionnelle et secondaire
pas encore mais l'expulsion
administrative c'est-à-dire en 48 heures
est possible c'est les 170 cas donc vous
avez alors ça c'est pour les squats
maintenant pour les locataires c'est une
autre histoire la nouveauté c'est que le
texte est rédigé de telle manière qu'il
va incriminer de vol
comme ça a été dit de vol de domicile
les locataires qui se maintiennent dans
leur logement après le jugement
d'expulsion alors je vous propose on va
reprendre voilà le point de vue des
propriétaires souvent petits
propriétaires qui attendaient ce texte
et puis ensuite on ira voir point de vue
des locataires mais on termine le tour
de table général bonsoir Jean-Paul sol
bonsoir et merci d'être là vous êtes le
président de la Chambre des
propriétaires du Grand Paris c'est le
bon moment parce que on est quand même
en pleine très hivernale on entendait la
présidente de la Fondation Abbé Pierre
dire il y a déjà la crise énergétique
l'inflation au supermarché elle est
bienvenu maintenant cette loi
d'abord que
nous nous serons nous nous trompons pas
pardon comment on disait tout à l'heure
on parle des squats on parle pas des
locataires on parle des squats donc moi
j'ai pris quelques chiffres que j'ai
tirés
de
infostat justice qui est le l'organe du
ministère de la Justice et
l'Insee donc aujourd'hui
selon les chiffres du ministère de la
Justice il y en a sens il y en a 5000
5000 litiges qui sont liés au squat ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que sur un
parc de logements bailleur locataire de
37 millions
ça représente
0,0134%. qu'ensuite
le délit squat parce que pour moi c'est
un délit je vous rappelle que la PPL qui
a été proposée met en exergue le
l'article 17 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme qui dit que le droit
de propriété est un droit inviolable et
ça crée donc là on est en train un peu
déborder c'est un délit pas un délit
donc ça touche les propriétaires ça
touche les locataires je voudrais
demander à Jean-Baptiste si demain il
part en vacances et qu'au bout d'une
semaine il rentre et que son logement
escoité quelqu'un a changé les clés
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire vous expliquer
je vous propose on va parler du texte il
y a d'un côté la question des squatteurs
c'est-à-dire les personnes et je parle
sous votre contrôle qui occupent
illicitement un logement et qui peut
être vide c'est bien ça de l'autre la
question des locataires qui n'arrivent
plus à verser leur loyer on est bien
d'accord je vous propose qu'on écoute
d'abord ça va vous faire plaisir ces
fameux propriétaires parce que pour eux
aussi c'est le parcours du combattant
parfois et vous allez le voir ils
estiment très clairement que et bien la
victime c'est eux c'est un reportage
d'Hélène Bonduelle regardez
pour ce propriétaire les problèmes ont
commencé en 2014 d'abord des retards de
paiement de son locataire puis depuis
2016 plus aucun règlement du loyer on a
mis en place un tableau Excel depuis
effectivement qu'on a lancé les
procédures contre ce locataire qui ne
règle pas nous doit après de 80 000 €,
79275 l'expulsion de son locataire
mauvais payeur a pourtant été prononcé
il y a 4 ans mais il est toujours dans
le logement aujourd'hui Yann Vando ne
sait plus vers qui se retourner pour
récupérer son bien c'est presque un
ressentiment de spoliation presque
puisque aujourd'hui on a un appartement
on peut pas savoir ce qu'on peut faire
par rapport à ça et on a aucun retour on
n'est pas aidé du tout par la préfecture
aujourd'hui pour cet avocat l'État est
fautif car il n'exécute pas les
décisions de justice on pourrait
vraiment travailler c'est pas au niveau
de la procédure judiciaire c'est au
niveau de l'exécution des décisions de
justice donc au niveau des préfectures
il y a encore beaucoup trop de dossiers
c'est la totalité de mes dossiers ou les
préfets n'exécutent pas les décisions
d'expulsion ça a été le cas pour ce
propriétaire en 2008 un bout de recours
pour expulser son squatteur il finit par
donner de sa personne je décide de faire
une manifestation avec mes amis avec ma
famille on était une trentaine de
personnes devant la maison pour comme on
dit aujourd'hui lui mettre la honte et
finalement c'est ça qui a marché parce
que il y avait des banderoles il y avait
des slogans et ce monsieur et sa famille
qui prétendait dans le quartier qui
vivait sur un grand pied que c'était des
bourgeois de la ville et qu'ils étaient
dans une situation parfaitement légale a
eu honte et finalement deux mois après
ça a marché il a quitté la maison
et il n'est pas le seul certains
propriétaires ont même fait la grève de
la faim ou dormis dans leur garage faute
de pouvoir accéder à leur logement et
parfois quand le squatteur quitte les
lieux c'est après avoir saccagé
l'appartement c'est ce qui est arrivé à
cette propriétaire
les radiateurs qui ont été arrachés la
plaque de cuisson littéralement explosé
les portes arrachés des des trous ici
les squatteurs ont même récidivé après
avoir quitté l'appartement ils se sont
réinstallés en toute illégalité au
rez-de-chaussée du même immeuble
Jean-Baptiste terreau vous pouvez les
entendre ces paroles là tout de même
elles sont aussi légitimes regardez ils
vous disent on a tout essayé les
huissiers les avocats la préfecture on
ne peut rien faire les procédures
prennent parfois jusqu'à des années
ce que nous essayons de faire nous quand
une personne ou une famille est
expulsion d'une part nous l'encourageons
à faire une demande d'Allo droit au
logement opposable elle est reconnue
comme tel mais elle n'est jamais en
logée
et donc le propriétaire à ce moment là
faut quand même le rappeler il est aussi
en droit de demander une indemnisation à
l'administration qui va d'indemniser
donc du retard dans le dans l'exécution
de justice et aussi qui se peuvent se
retrouver à ne pas réduire leur niveau
de vie ça peut exister voire même
déménager oui c'est vrai mais n'oubliez
pas que 72% des logements locatifs sont
détenus par des grands propriétaires en
France donc c'est quand même un élément
qu'il faut dont les bailleurs sociaux je
veux dire bon donc là on a une loi qui
va vraiment s'appliquer à tout le monde
quel que soit la situation sociale du
propriétaire si je peux dire donc on va
voir des locataires qui ont des
difficultés à payer leur loyer
aujourd'hui
d'autant plus que les charges augmentent
très rapidement on a une inflation le
produit alimentaire les gens la fin du
mois ils ont du mal les loyers ont
augmenté depuis 20-30 ans enfin depuis
déjà un peu plus et les appels ont été
baissés donc on a service social on a
même une crise sociale qui est en train
d'arriver à se demander même si au fond
il y a pas cette idée de on criminalise
les locataires qui veulent pas quitter
leur logement après un jugement
d'expulsion
tout simplement parce que il y a une un
risque d'un payer qui va débarquer
massif peut-être qu'effectivement on va
avoir beaucoup de locataire qui vont
avoir du mal à payer leur loyer vous
savez quand on voit que les tours
d'efforts
nous les familles qui viennent nous voir
ont des taux d'efforts c'est-à-dire
consacre 40 50 60 % de leurs revenus
pour se loger voilà c'est une réalité
c'est pas la même que celle de il y a 30
ans et aujourd'hui les loyers sont très
chers les revenus sont bas et les
locataires modestes sont de plus en plus
modestes et d'ailleurs sont en cours de
paupérisation on a une paupérisation
aujourd'hui des locataires parce que
ceux qui la défendre quand on entend la
réalité des mallogers parce que ceux qui
ont des revenus ils ont accès à la
propriété je rajoutais aussi autre chose
les accidents la propriété en difficulté
aussi ils vont subir le même châtiment
c'est à dire que si parte pas
à l'issue d'un jugement d'expulsion
c'est-à-dire leur bien est saisi et et
expulser
expulser à la suite de la saisie de leur
bien
si ils partent pas pareil la prison donc
vous voyez je pense que dans une forme
de cruauté sociale qui est démesurée je
dirais il faut trouver un équilibre on
revient à la question voilà pour
l'instant de l'opportunité du moment
parce que c'est vrai que voilà la crise
énergétique elle percute tout le monde
et vraiment en premier lieu les plus
modestes c'est le fond de la pensée
c'est que le droit au logement pose des
vraies questions qui sont des questions
pertinentes et qui sont juste celles de
la du pouvoir d'achat de l'accès au
logement et je ne les balais pas du tout
en revanche les réponses qui sont mises
en face me semble absolument pas
pertinente la bonne réponse c'est celle
du soutien au pouvoir d'achat c'est ce
qu'on a voté de l'hémicycle notamment
ces dernières semaines et ces derniers
mois c'est le fait de mettre en place un
bouclier tarifaire sur le prix de
l'énergie si vous avez aussi accepté les
amendements à droite sur ce texte
politique pour avoir les voix de DLR de
verser des chèques aux familles qu'on a
le plus besoin sur l'énergie par exemple
12 de foyers qui vont pouvoir en
bénéficier la réponse ça ne peut pas
être d'accepter que des propriétaires en
France soient spoilés de leurs biens et
de leurs droits au regard d'un contexte
et on peut pas accepter dans un état de
droit qui est la France d'avoir des
logements qui soient squattés d'avoir
des locataires qui pendant des années se
maintiennent dans un logement sans me
payer ce maintien dans un logement alors
qu'il ne paie pas leur loyer et vous
l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs il y a des
décisions d'expulsion qui sont prises
par le juge il y a toute une procédure
judiciaire qui va être continuée à être
maintenue mais là vous nous dites oui il
y a des mauvais payeurs en France qui
sont de mauvaise foi on peut pas
accepter les comportements malhonnêtes
sous réserve d'un contexte qui est
difficile vous posez des questions qui
sont pertinentes mais les réponses que
vous mettez en face elles sont tout
simplement contraintes moi je vous pose
la question des mauvais payeurs ils
existent en France quand on regarde les
chiffres sur les signalements qui
parviennent
au ministère on est 50 000 signalements
chaque année donc il y a une espèce
d'angoisse ça existe du propriétaire il
y a seulement 12000 expulsions par an en
2021 c'était beaucoup plus en 2019 pas
loin de 17000 moi je voudrais savoir ce
qu'on appelle un mauvais payeur c'est à
dire que si c'est quelqu'un qui a les
moyens de payer son loyer qui ne payent
pas c'est un mauvais payeur si c'est
quelqu'un qui n'a plus les moyens de
payer son loyer parce que malgré les
aides que j'en aimer c'est bien de
rappeler les aides à chaque fois vous
avez raison de le faire je comprends
pourquoi vous le faites d'ailleurs mais
sauf que si ça correspond pas du tout à
la situation sociale si en ce moment les
prix explosent si en ce moment les
pauvres augmentent si le chômage
augmente vous pouvez rappeler les
quelques aides que vous avez fait si le
compte n'est pas le contenu n'est pas
quand on a des gens quand on a des gens
aujourd'hui qui ne peuvent pas et c'est
tout le problème de cette proposition de
loi les gens de mauvaise foi les gens
de mauvaise foi les délinquants tous
tout cela on est d'accord qu'il faut les
sanctionner on est d'accord qu'il faut
ne pas les soutenir mais quand on se
quand on voit un petit peu les gens qui
sont en difficulté de loyer quand on
voit quand on est dans des associations
qui aident les mal logés comme par
exemple l'association Droit au logement
quand on voit la réalité de qui sont ces
gens là croyez moi bien c'est bien
souvent simplement des gens qui à un
moment perdant d'emploi sont dans un
divorce sur une situation qui change se
retrouve en un pays de loyer c'est vrai
que c'est pas très drôle pour le
propriétaire donc il faut mettre en
place un accompagnement social il faut
faire quelque chose pour que le
propriétaire puisse retrouver ses loyers
moi je ne suis pas en train de dire
propriétaire là c'est toi ne fait
pas la différence je dois juste terminer
là-dessus cette fois ne fait pas la
différence à partir du moment où vous
n'avez pas payé votre loyer pendant
quelques mois vous êtes maintenant
considéré comme un voleur c'est
l'article 1 qui dit l'occupation d'un
logement par exemple où le bail a été
résilié parce que il n'y a plus il n'y
avait pas le loyer n'a pas été payé et
bien c'est assimilé à du vol et donc
vous risquez des années de prison est-ce
que c'est ça la France est-ce que c'est
ça la France de l'abbé Pierre
certainement pas j'aimerais que vous
vous entend ce que vous dites sur le
volet des impayés et là-dessus on peut
ne pas être d'accord mais je remarque
que les articles qui touchent au squat
pur vous n'allez pas aller voter non
plus et parce que il y en a pas un seul
qui fait la différence j'ai expliqué ça
dans la musique tout à l'heure vous
faites la confusion à chaque fois entre
toutes les situations pas un seul de vos
articles distincts justement le cas de
mauvaise foi ou le cas d'entrer par
effraction la violation de domicile le
cas d'un pays de loyer tout est mis dans
le terme squat monsieur cache pas
la question de la mauvaise foi c'est
quelque chose de très compliqué ça
serait que souvent devant les tribunaux
aujourd'hui cette loi elle va permettre
au juge de faciliter les avis
d'expulsion sans que le locataire puisse
vraiment avoir les moyens je dirais pas
de se défendre il peut aller devant le
juge expliquer son dossier mais ça va
accélérer les choses vous vous voyez la
réalité du terrain sur le Grand Paris
c'est mauvais payeur de mauvaise foi
combien sont-ils avoir des ordres de
grandeur je voudrais des barres déjà
revenir à la genèse de notre débat qui
est la loi anti-squate donc on peut pas
assimiler des locataires des squatteurs
vous êtes d'accord mais pour l'instant
pour l'instant on parle des squats
aujourd'hui je vois on a vu le
témoignage de de propriétaire qui a dû
certainement acheter un logement locatif
à crédit pour prévoir sa retraite qui
sera un peu réduite
et qui prévoit sur l'avenir et il achète
son appartement à crédit il dit les
loyers vont payer le crédit et puis
subitement le local le locataire oui
devient
occupant Sandrine ne paye plus le loyer
la banque elle est la tempe
le
locataire il est payé le loyer tous les
mois évidemment sur le droit des
propriétaires il y a effectivement
depuis quelques années je dis pas que
c'est bien ou que c'est pas bien mais il
y a parfois
une on surrajoute le droit au logement
au droit de propriété là vous allez
avoir des délais de procédure qui vont
être largement réduits puisque
finalement les les délais qui vont être
accordés au locataire indélicat ont
passé de 3 à 1 an maximum ça ça va dans
le bon sens pour vous j'imagine ça va
dans le bon sens mais vous savez quand
et on ne fait pas de gaieté de coeur
parce que on vient pas son locataire
parce qu'il a une sale tête ou
qu'il a défilé pour le droit au logement
ou une autre cause non je plaisante
le locataire non mais on avait une
discussion intéressante tout à l'heure
tous les deux et on a échangé et c'était
plutôt positif
donc quand le locataire est en impayé
qu'il devient par jugement un
occupant son droit inutile c'est-à-dire
que le juge prononce l'acquisition de la
clause résolutoire
le juge dépend du ministère de la
Justice ensuite la décision doit être
appliquée par le préfet qui dépend du
ministère de l'Intérieur et le préfet
pour
prononcer l'expulsion
doit saisir dans chaque préfecture la
CAPEX donc l'administration a toujours
des temps entre l'audience que il faut
obtenir jusqu'à l'effectivité de
l'audience
on peut imaginer que le juge se
prononcera plus rapidement en revanche
la durée moyenne pour lui
on était à 3 ans mais c'est ce que je
vous dis c'est que le rendu de la
décision de justice elle sera peut-être
accélérer en revanche vous passez devant
la commission de coordination et
d'action de prévention des expulsions
locatives à la préfecture et s'il préfet
estime qu'il y a un trouble à l'ordre
public qui donne pas l'expulsion donc on
peut dire
s'intéresser aux droits au logement des
locataires à présent pour l'autre côté
bonsoir Sébastien de l'augus et merci
d'avoir patienté celle des quatre
colonnes duplex avec nous vous êtes
député la France insoumise des
Bouches-du-Rhône et vous avez
vous-même merci merci on y est très
sensible vous êtes député je le disais
vous avez été vous-même victime d'une
expulsion c'était il y a bien longtemps
vous aviez bien 25 ans vous avez vous
occupez un logement social racontez-nous
ce qui s'est passé vous avez d'ailleurs
témoigné dans l'hémicycle au cours de ce
débat
oui bah j'ai décidé de ramener un peu
d'humanité dans dans les débats puisque
moi j'avais 25 ans j'avais deux enfants
à bas âge et j'ai été expulsé devant
logement parce que j'étais sans droit ni
titre c'est-à-dire que c'était ma mère
qui était signataire du bail et donc du
coup moi le monde bailleur social m'a
dit très clairement nous on doit
augmenter le loyer parce que ta mère ça
faisait un certain nombre d'années
qu'elle était dans le logement
maintenant il faut que tu t'en ailles
parce que de toute façon tu es pas
signataire du bail et donc je me suis
retrouvé donc jeudi 12 avril 2012 à part
jugement à être à la rue et je me suis
retrouvé avec mes enfants à la rue donc
c'est important aujourd'hui de regarder
la loi de notre œil et de se dire
qu'est-ce qu'elle est le réel sujet les
petits propriétaires qui ont des
personnes qui squattent leur logement on
n'est pas contre nous on n'est pas
contre ces gens-là au contraire on est
on a de la peine pour eux mais là où on
est en inverse le débat c'est que le
débat n'est pas justement sur cette loi
là mais elle est elle est très elle est
pour la construction des logements
sociaux pour le droit à un logement
si je vais prendre Sébastien de l'augure
on n'a pas ils vont aller s'il vous
plaît pour bien comprendre la situation
dans le cas précis vous n'avez pas pu
bénéficier du bailleur social d'un d'un
renouvellement du contrat de bail alors
que votre mère était partie pour pour
vous payer les les loyers vous pouviez
le faire pour quelle raison alors
évidemment qu'on peut éloigner on
pouvait le faire bien sûr que la vie est
compliquée quand elle était compliquée
pour moi à l'époque et que j'ai eu des
retards de loyer mais en tout cas moi je
suis pas parti avec une dette locative
je suis parti parce que je n'étais pas
signataire du bail donc du coup j'ai été
considéré comme un squatteur et la siste
loi passe maintenant je serai considéré
comme un voleur et on voit bien monsieur
kasbariian qui a donc retiré son
amendement mais j'aurais pu avoir 7500
euros d'amende et six mois de prison
ferme or j'étais à l'époque chez ma mère
merci beaucoup pour ce témoignage merci
Sébastien delogu député la France
insoumise des Bouches-du-Rhône Maud
Brejon on entendait le ministre Olivier
Klein dire ce matin sur France Info une
expuls sur locative c'est toujours un
échec c'est ce qui est arrivé à ce
député aujourd'hui on a l'impression
quand même qui a il y a pas une volonté
politique au plus haut niveau du
gouvernement de porter ce texte
réellement est-ce que est-ce que c'est
le moment il y a une volonté totale de
la majorité la majorité parlementaire à
laquelle j'appartiens de porter ce texte
je suis en plein soutien de mon collègue
Guillaume caisse barian d'ailleurs c'est
un texte qu'on a co-construit j'ai
beaucoup de collègues de la majorité qui
portent des amendements et un texte dont
on est fier il y a un problème d'accès
au logement je ne le dis pas je ne
craignais pas que ça précarise
sur lequel il faut appuyer par exemple
le fait que l'ensemble des communes
respecte le seuil de minimum 25% de
logements sociaux par commune c'est loin
d'être le cas moi je vis dans un
département les Hauts-de-Seine qui est
en département riche je pourrais vous
citer un certain nombre de communes qui
ne remplissent pas cette obligation
peut-être que c'est là dessus par
exemple qu'on pourrait avancer je pense
qu'en revanche demandez aux
propriétaires et notamment propriétaire
modestes parce qu'il y en a de rogner
sur leur propre droit sur leur propre
niveau de vie sur leur propre pouvoir
d'achat pour compenser un autre problème
par ailleurs et juste pas la bonne
solution et à mon avis l'ensemble des
Françaises et des Français qui nous
écoutent comprennent parfaitement que en
France on n'a pas accepté le squat qu'on
n'a pas accepté des impayés de loyer qui
durent six mois des mois et des mois
d'affichage politique avec ce texte et
donc c'est pas vers la droite je pose la
question on a tous mangé dans mes
circonscriptions des gens à qui c'est
arrivé on a on a auditionné on a
au-dessus de Monsieur je me suis
toujours opposé de façon extrêmement
claire à l'extrême droite c'est pas à
moi il faut faire le procès
en l'occurrence qui avait une
proposition de loi sur le même
positionner des gens en commission un
certain nombre de familles de jeunes
femmes à qui c'est arrivé
euh alors bien sûr que ça ne concerne
pas la majorité des Français c'est pas
pourtant qui c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut pas apporter de réponse et c'est ce
que fait Guillaume important ce texte
allez on termine ce débat par un rapide
tour de table aujourd'hui Aurélien
Pradier où le voir tâcher pardonnez-moi
Aurélie ça n'a rien à voir en même temps
vous annoncer pardonnez-moi quand vous
voulez louer un bien vous avez tout le
monde le sait une tonne de garantie à
donner même quand vous avez un salaire
correct ça montre bien la méfiance des
propriétaires comment on fait pour
rassurer dans ces cas-là si vous n'aimez
pas ce texte qu'est-ce que vous proposez
pour les rassurer alors
une garantie universelle des loyers qui
fait que quand il y a un impayé de loyer
l'État prend le relais pour que le
propriétaire ne soit pas en difficulté
pour le coup de la mesure il se chiffre
si on si on prend une petite taxation
sur sur chaque propriétaire allez 70 ou
80 euros par an ça vous ça vous finance
une garantie universelle pour tous les
locataires je crois pas que ce soit
absolument insurmontable et quel droit
ça mettrait en place dans notre pays
parce que là tout ce qu'on va avoir
c'est une augmentation du nombre de
personnes sans abri et j'aimerais bien
savoir comment le gouvernement va
traiter ça Jean-Baptiste héros pour
conclure ce débat puis je voudrais la
parole également oui bon bah on a le
phénomène du squat reste néanmoins assez
marginal et touche souvent des immeubles
plutôt que des appartements privés les
impayés de loyer aussi sont marginaux ce
qu'on aux alentours de 2% dans le
secteur privé 4% secteur HLM pour nous
il faut renforcer le droit au logement
parce qu'on a une crise du logement qui
progresse faut rappeler que le nombre
d'expulsions augmente tout simplement
parce que les loyers augmentent quand
vous prenez les statistiques sur les
jugements d'expulsion au début des
années 80 on était aux alentours de
60000 aujourd'hui on a 120 000 jugement
d'expulsion on était à 3500 expulsions
Manu military aujourd'hui on est à 17
millions
donc vous voyez on a une situation les
et les taux d'efforts la part
engagement à côté de ce texte dernier
point pour conclure
les propriétaires l'objectif c'était de
vous rassurer c'est fait c'est une
avancée d'un mot en ce qui concerne la
loi anti-squat oui dans la mesure où
j'espère qu'elle va être votée je
voudrais rajouter une chose et rebondir
sur une remarque qui a fait tout à
l'heure mon voisin du dalle rapidement
je vous promets
sur le on a un problème effectivement
aujourd'hui avec les logements vacants
en France alors l'Insee dit qu'il y en a
trois millions mais il y en aurait un
million d'immédiatement
requisitionnables disponible
le problème c'est les travaux la
faisabilité et toute la rénovation que
vous allez en parler en dehors de ce
studio le logement c'est un priorité
pour les Français mais il a beaucoup de
dimensions on voulait parler de ce texte
ce soir merci merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé
on va accueillir à présent nos deux
grands témoins pour expliquer la guerre
de Poutine qui nous apparaît si
irrationnel et bien ils se sont plongés
dans l'histoire et dans le parcours du
dictateur russe KGB mafia soif de
revanche sur le passé soviétique cette
guerre est tout sauf un accident de
l'histoire Gallia Karman et Stéphane
Courtois publient le Livre noir de
Vladimir Poutine chez Robert Laffont il
nous rejoignent juste après l'invitation
Marco Polo
si on vous invite Gallia à Kerman et
Stéphane Courtois c'est parce que vous
avez tenté de percer le mystère Poutine
avec vous nous voulons comprendre le
parcours et l'idéologie du maître du
Kremlin jusqu'où peut-il aller dans sa
guerre contre l'Ukraine lui qui n’hésite
plus à agiter la menace nucléaire c'est
un homme très dangereux aujourd'hui sera
acculé ces petits et un rat acculé est
un rat dangereux Gallia Kerman Stéphane
Courtois vous avez en commun la
profession d'historien impossible
Stéphane Courtois donne pas citer votre
best-seller mondial sur l'ampleur des
crimes du régime soviétique quant à vous
Galia Karmann dissident russe né à
Moscou journaliste grande spécialiste du
monde soviétique vous dirigez la
rédaction de descerussy ensemble vous
publiez aujourd'hui un nouveau livre
noir sur les multiples facettes de
Vladimir Poutine
soviétiqueuse dites-vous politique de
déstabilisation de l'Occident relation
avec les oligarques et l'Église
orthodoxe pour asseoir sa toute
puissance comment ce lieutenant-colonel
issu d'un milieu modeste est-il parvenu
à se hisser au sommet du pouvoir nous
essayons de retracer le chemin de
Poutine et de donner une vision de sa
gouvernance en avançant la thèse que ces
méthodes et sa tactique sont inspirées
du KGB Poutine l'éternel homme du KGB de
simple agent a directeur des
Renseignements russes l'homme est marqué
par cette culture quasi maffieuse sans
oublier son idéologie rétrograde tournée
vers le passé communiste de la Russie le
maître du Kremlin a toujours refusé
l'effondrement de l'URSS en 1991 en URSS
après sa dissolution 1025 millions de
personnes d'origine russe ce sont
retrouvés d'un jour à l'autre dans des
pays étrangers
et cela a été une vraie catastrophe
humanitaire la reconquête des frontières
de l'empire tsariste une obsession de
Vladimir Poutine guidé par cet objectif
il déclenchera plusieurs guerres
meurtrières Tchétchénie Géorgie Crimée
et aujourd'hui l'Ukraine mais qu'en
est-il de l'avenir Gallia Ackerman et
Stéphane Courtois ce régime peut-il
tenir les valeurs de la démocratie
finiront-elles par renverser Vladimir
Poutine à vous la parole
bonsoir Galia Karman bonsoir et bonsoir
Stéphane Courtois merci infiniment à
tous les deux d'être sur ce plateau on
va parler de ce livre bien sûr
commençons par les les racines même de
l'invasion russe c'est au fond pour
comprendre cette guerre qui nous semble
si rationnelle que vous replongez dans
la destinée dans le parcours de cette
homo-soviétiqueuse qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire précisément
homosophie c'est en latin bien sûr le
mot soviétique n'existait pas mais bon
c'est un pseudo latin ça veut dire homme
soviétique et homme soviétique ça veut
dire un homme qui a les valeurs du
système soviétique qui a été élevé à
l'intérieur du système soviétique et qui
agit en tant que tel ça veut dire que
tout ce qu'il a gardé il ne sait jamais
des prix de cette culture du KGB dans
l'empire soviétique cette culture
mafieuse vous la décrivez comme telle
c'est ce qu'il constitue encore
aujourd'hui oui alors on a dit
homo-soviétique US effectivement
puisqu'il a vécu jusqu'à ses 40 ans en
Union soviétique et il a totalement
adhéré à ses valeurs mais il y a un
élément supplémentaire c'est que
homo-soviétique
US mais cagibiste et ça c'est très
particulier voilà c'est très particulier
puisque le KGB depuis son origine en
1917 jusqu'en 1991 a toujours été
l'institution de la terreur sans
laquelle le régime n'aurait pas tenu
culture de la terreur de la violence de
la duplicité de la violence du secret de
la duplicité
mensonge ça c'est très important parce
que auquel je vais on élève les gens on
les éduque au mensonges
en fait Poutine est une sorte d'officier
traitant ou de super officiers traitant
qui a fait cette école du KGB ensuite
l'école de l'Institut anthropov pour les
espions et qui sait manipuler les gens
qui sait
mentir surtout sur ces intentions sur ce
qu'il est en train de faire sur ces
plans etc ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'au fond sa volonté est
rétrograde en elle-même c'est à dire que
ça n'est pas une fuite en avance et une
fuite en avant vers le passé il veut
retrouver la gloire passée de la
puissance soviétique
pas avant même d'être élu président en
2000 au mois de mars il a il a fait une
déclaration très très claire celui qui
ne regrette pas l'Union soviétique n'a
pas de cœur et celui qui veut la
reconstituer à l'identique n'a pas de
tête mais ça n'interdit pas de la
reconstituer d'une autre manière et dès
le départ alors qu'il est premier
ministre Delphine il trinque c'est l'une
des anecdotes à la santé de Staline son
maître son modèle oui c'est son modèle
de même qui vend le terrible c'est à
dire
un gouverneur un
peu importe quel titre donnait à cela
leader qui
règne par la terreur qui règne aussi par
la subversion et qui a des projets
purement colonialisme et impérialiste et
il y a encore une phrase il y en a celle
que Stéphane a cité j'ajouterai une
autre quand il était encore Premier
ministre avant même d'être élu président
il a assisté à la fête du check-list
tchéquiste c'est la chica c'est
l'ancêtre du cachebé du FFB crée tout de
suite après la Révolution d'Octobre et
il a dit en plaisantant ou peut-être
on ne plaisantant pas il a dit à ses
camarades donc le corps de checkistes
rassemblait à l'occasion il a dit je
vous rapporte que j'ai rempli le premier
étape de la mission à infiltré le
gouvernement vous voyez donc tout cela a
été conçu des sa nominations et
certainement il y a eu des forces qui
étaient derrière lui même si à ce jour
nous n'avons pas pu vraiment les
identifier peut-être un groupe de
généraux du cashb qui est à essayer par
son intermédiaire de revenir aux
commandes donc Poutine avait très
certainement un projet impérial qui il
lui a fallu dès le restant 20 ans pour
le c'est autant de livre noir de Poutine
que celui de notre aveuglement sur lui
de celui de nos naïvetés on va on va y
revenir dans un instant il y a un
chapitre qui m'a qui m'a interpellé
c'est la langue de Poutine cette
vulgarité cette violence dans les mots
écoutez 1999 à propos des tchétchène
[Musique]
jusque dans les chiottes il y a beaucoup
d'autres exemples que vous citez de
Verbatim de Poutine cette violence là
dans les mots elle a forcément des
conséquences aussi dans la société russe
bien entendu mais ce que reflète ce type
d'expression et le chapitre que vous
évoquez c'est le fait que cet homme du
KGB qui est déjà un homme de grande
violence et de mensonges et de secrets
etc c'est ta coquiner avec des gens de
la mafia du grand banditisme et donc là
on est on est on est tout à fait dans ce
type d'ailleurs le code d'honneur
c'est le même code d'honneur c'est la
confiance et la confiance qui repose sur
l'assassinat à partir du moment où vous
assassinez quelqu'un qu'on vous a
ordonné d'assassiner vous êtes dans la
mafia un homme d'honneur et dans le kg
vous êtes un homme de confiance
l'Ukraine gallea Kerman obsède depuis
toujours Vladimir Poutine en 2004 quand
victorienne ou covid gagne l'élection
que cette élection est contestée partout
dans le pays par les observateurs
internationaux il est furieux déjà
je pense que Poutine a quelque chose de
très personnel contre le crâne vous
savez parfois pour cirer on analyse
leurs enfants ou ceux qui leur est
arrivé au cours de leur vie et donc pour
Poutine je ne sais pas quel était
l'impulsion initiale il y a un côté
rationnel c'est que il est impossible de
reconstruire l'Empire sans l'Ukraine
mais il y a aussi quelque chose de très
personnel à plusieurs reprises il a
perdu en Ukraine il a perdu les
élections que vous avez évoquées 2004
félicité il y a nos coach et ensuite
c'est le peuple qui a insisté pour qu'il
y ait le troisième tour des élections et
c'est l'homme que les services secrets
russes ensemble avec des complicités
ukrainiennes ont essayé d'empoisonner
victorious chinko qui a gagné l'élection
ensuite il arrive Poutine à installer
quand même il y a nos coach en 2010 il y
a un travail de sape énorme il
qui sont à l'oeuvre il y a nos coach
gagne et bien en 2013 il est renversé
encore une fois 2013 débute
et ensuite même maintenant après
l'annexion de la Crimée les Russes ont
dépensés en argent fous pour soudoyer à
tous les niveaux en Ukraine en Ukraine
des gens qui pourraient prendre la
relève et installer finalement un régime
dans les rues sont besoin et là encore
ça n'a pas mal alors vous montrez très
bien dans le livre les guerres qu'il
nous mènent Gary brides depuis des
décennies sur le terrain de
l'information des cyberattaques des
politiques de la propagande jusqu'à
l'art dans certaines capitales de nos
propres élites on s'est aveuglé
longtemps
est-ce qu'il y a encore trop
d'indulgence parmi les élites françaises
vis-à-vis de Poutine on s'est beaucoup
aveuglé et puis il y a des gens qui en
ailleurs il y a des gens d'une part qui
sont un peu fascinés par cet homme qui
qui a l'air puissant voire même très
puissant et qui fait gagner beaucoup
d'argent il y a un phénomène de
corruption qui est très important
prenons ne serait-ce que l'exemple de
l'Allemagne le l'ex chancelier Schreder
qui a signé tous ces contrats gaziers
qui nous mettent aujourd'hui enfin qui
nous mettait quasiment pied et point
liés dans les mains de Poutine il
pouvait couper le robinet du gaz quand
il voulait
et là on est en pleine corruption parce
que Monsieur
récents qui montrent une forme de
pression américaine sur Zelenski pour le
pousser à négocier lui s'y refuse tant
que Poutine et là il craint des grosses
attaques qui a fait rentrer dans l'hiver
sans électricité est-ce que la victoire
des Ukrainiens encore possible la
victoire des Ukrainiens est possible le
temps que le peuple ukrainien croit en
la victoire et c'est très important
c'est pas
qu'il faut négocier il faut négocier au
fond avec le peuple craignant et si
zelinsky fait quelque chose que ne veut
pas le peuple craignant il va valser
merci beaucoup merci infiniment je vous
conseille le Livre noir de Vladimir
Poutine chez Robert Lafont c'est
implacable et c'est lucide sur le
dictateur russe et la conclusion est
très claire vous enjoignez les Européens
à sortir de la naïveté un jour ou
l'autre l'Ukraine rentrera dans l'OTAN
nous dites-vous vous allez très loin
merci à vous merci beaucoup on va
accueillir à présent nos affranchis pour
leur partie prix ce soir elles sont
trois elles amont d'un Gava vu du
perchoir va nous parler de cette
nouvelle Assemblée tellement chronophage
pour les députés et bien qu'il réclame
de nouvelles méthodes le baromètre Doxat
Céline Brach qui porte ce mois-ci sur la
droite à la veille du congrès des
républicains et puis le parti pris de
l'écho de Fanny guinochet annonce choc
d'Emmanuel Macron détendent les RER aux
grandes métropoles coup de génie ou
coûte nous affranchit les voici on
commence avec vous Elsa vous allez nous
parler des députés qui travaillent
travaillent c'est faute de majorité
absolue faut sier alors ils sont
fatigués ou pas nos députés alors vous
en trouverez pas un pour vous dire face
caméra oui je suis épuisé je suis crevée
ils ont bien conscience que c'est un peu
difficile pour tout le monde que ce
serait un petit peu indécent de ce
plaindre écoutez
faut pas qu'on se plainte déjà parce
qu'on a des gens qui ramassent nos
poubelles de nuit on a des infirmières
qui travaillent la nuit également et
donc tu en as voulu être député c'est
pour y mettre de l'énergie et dans un
rythme qui est un peu infernal alors
hors micro sans se plaindre évidemment
il reconnaisse qu'ils sont quand même un
peu épuisés c'est vrai que le rythme est
très soutenu on a eu des sens qu'on
finit tard rien que ce mois-ci par
exemple sur le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif deux séances une à une
heure du matin une à trois heures du
matin pareil sur la loop me la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur et les députés
ils sont tous d'accord passez une
certaine heure les débats sont pas
franchement de qualité
c'est pas une question de trop ou passer
travailler c'est parfois de prendre plus
de temps dans les journées alors on peut
travailler jusqu'à 1h du matin c'est pas
le problème mais finir un texte à 6h du
matin c'est pas bien les séances de nuit
elles sont on voit on le voit c'est tout
le tour à ces moments-là qui a des
accidents à toujours à ce moment-là qui
a des injures qui a des cris qui que
qu'on a une image déplorable tout
simplement le problème n'est pas tant le
rythme en soi c'est après la qualité des
discussions qu'on a quand on siège de 10
heures à deux heures du matin donc ça il
faut qu'il y ait une discussion moi j'y
suis pas fermé maintenant je sais aussi
pourquoi je suis là donc on savait qu'on
allait travailler beaucoup
alors il travaille vraiment plus tard
qu'avant ou pas il y a pas forcément
plus de séances de nuit qu'avant mais
c'est vrai qu'avec la majorité le
relative on en a parlé chaque voix elle
compte beaucoup plus donc les députés on
les appelle on les mobilise on leur dit
vous devez être en séance et pour ça il
y a donc deux inquiétudes une bah c'est
un peu sur le sens qu'on donne à son
mandat député et une autre et bah c'est
sur le risque d'être très présent en
séance mais très absent dans sa
circonscription
les votes se jouent parfois à quelques à
quelques voix et donc nous sommes plus
souvent que par le passé requis dans
l'hémicycle et on a besoin aussi d'être
dans notre circonscription parce qu'on
n'est pas un monde député quand on est
décoté déconnecté de ce que l'on nous
dit sur le terrain donc on a besoin de
cette articulation et c'est vrai que la
majorité relative rend cette possibilité
extrêmement compliquée avec une majorité
relative les députés et en particulier
de la majorité sont obligés d'être
présents pour relever la main ou appuyer
sur le bouton
H24 jour et nuit y compris le vendredi
voir le samedi dans un certain nombre de
cas et je pense qu'on peut faire mieux
alors qu'est-ce qui propose pour changer
les méthodes de travail alors il y a une
quasianimité sur le fait de dire on ne
siège pas le vendredi comme ça ça permet
de rentrer en circonscription plutôt
puis une quasi inanimité pour dire que
ça dépend pas que de ni des députés ni
de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale mais aussi du gouvernement
puisque c'est lui qui tient aussi
l'ordre du jour le message est passé
pour les ministres qui nous écouteraient
ce soir merci beaucoup Elsa Céline
baromètre odoxa que vous nous révélez
comme chaque mois partenaire des chaînes
parlementaires gros plan ce mois-ci sur
la droite à la veille du congrès des
républicains mais attention petit
préalable ça n'est pas des intentions de
votre dont vous allez nous parler ce
soir mais d'indications de l'opinion sur
les républicains voilà parce que
attention de votre ça voudrait dire
qu'on sonde les quelques cent mille
adhérents là non onde les Français
c'est-à-dire les Français adultes 52
millions de personnes et puis le corps
des sympathisants c'est à dire ceux qui
se sentent proches des sympathisants les
républicains c'est à dire 30 ou 40 fois
plus que les adhérents oui bien sûr donc
ça peut être un peu différent du vote
final mais alors justement tout à fait
les trois prétendants à la présidence
des républicains sont dans l'opinion
assez peu populaire enfin certains même
ne sont pas connus c'est le cas
d'Aurélien Pradier on peut le voir
d'ailleurs dans dans votre classement au
doxa ce mois-ci les sympathisants des
républicains en revanche eux les
connaissent bien qu'en pensent-ils des
trois candidats en lice alors on va voir
les trois candidats avec envers
l'adhésion en jaune
[Musique]
une bonne opinion de ces parties mais de
ces partis politiques mais on voit
finalement que les républicains se
situent pas si mal que ça dans le
classement
35%, ça veut dire autant que Renaissance
le parti présidentiel et pratiquement
autant que les deux leaders c'est à dire
le rassemblement national Europe
Écologie Les Verts finalement et bien
devant aussi le Parti socialiste qui est
l'autre ancien grand parti on va dire de
la 5e République la petite difficulté on
voit pas ici le détail mais c'est que ce
qui aiment les républicains se sont
surtout des gens qui ont 65 ans et plus
c'est pas mal parce que ce sont des gens
qui votent mais ça en fait un parti un
peu vieillissant et tout cela nous mène
à la question des alliances alors 56%
des Français souhaitent au moins une
alliance entre partie et ce chiffre
montre à 73% quand on interroge les
sympathisants les républicains des
alliances oui mais quelles alliances à
droite voilà alors ça a beaucoup changé
parce qu'il y a très peu de temps les
républicains ne voulaient pas entendre
parler d'alliance maintenant ils veulent
bien une alliance et c'est vrai que vous
avez raison c'est quelle alliance et
bien aujourd'hui
rien ne s'impose très clairement mais
quand même on en a 45% des sympathisants
LR qui vont nous dire plutôt avec la
majorité présidentielle 38% pour le RN
31% pour reconquête donc vous voyez
elles sont complètement divisées
qui on peut dire n'est pas le plus
proche des centriste mais c'est
intéressant parce que ça veut dire aussi
qu'au sein des sympathisants LR
aujourd'hui on a plutôt plus des
centristes que des gens qui se sentent
vraiment à droite qui pour beaucoup ont
déjà migré soit au rassemblement
national soit chez reconquête reconquête
très bien compris le baromètre odoxa de
novembre et le Congrès ce weekend on en
parlera bien sûr ici même dès la semaine
prochaine Fanny vous voulez revenir sur
cette proposition d'Emmanuel Macron un
projet d'investissement massif pour
étendre les RER aux grandes métropoles
parce que le RER ce n'est pas que Paris
dit le président ça c'est vrai mais
est-ce que c'est faisable alors le vrai
sujet parce qu'Emmanuel Macron présente
donc cette proposition comme un super
objectif écologique économique pour une
meilleure qualité de la vie mais la
question qui vient tout de suite
derrière c'est ok mais comment va-t-on
payer parce que normalement les RER se
sont les régions qui les financé
évidemment les régions n'ont pas les
moyens de financer des investissements
aussi importants alors comment on peut
se partager la charge entre l'État la
SNCF les régions la facture promet
d'être gigantesque alors justement on en
a une idée du montant de cette facture
une petite idée Jean-Pierre phare endoux
le patron de la SNCF disait en juillet
dernier que pour 13 RER nouveau RER il
faudrait 13 milliards d'euros donc c'est
assez simple surtout que il ne suffit
pas de les construire après il faut les
entretenir et ça aussi ça coûte de
l'argent et quand on voit les RER
franciliens on peut se dire qu'il y a eu
des petits soucis sur les
investissements mais c'est le en même
temps d'Emmanuel Macron on n'arrive pas
à entretenir des RER qui ont maintenant
presque 30 ans mais on en construit de
nouveau sans avoir l'argent donc c'est
un coup de com finalement du président
ça y ressemble quand même surtout dans
la forme une annonce un dimanche soir
sur Youtube le gouvernement n'était même
pas au courant sans vraiment de plan de
bataille c'est un vieux serpent de mer
en plus ce RER alors évidemment ça donne
des gages au président de région qui
sont très contents quoi applaudis tout
ça quand même dans un contexte
d'inflation ou déjà la SNCF par exemple
parle d'un surcoût de 500 millions
d'euros n'arrivent pas à boucler son
budget Valérie Pécresse elle envisage de
dans la région Île-de-France d'augmenter
le passe Navigo à 90 euros donc c'est
évidemment une annonce intéressante qui
intéresse en plus au premier rang les
Français parce que ce sont des choses
des améliorations du quotidien mais qui
risque de susciter énormément de
déception attention aux annonces choc
quand elles sont pas suivies des faits
avec anticipation merci beaucoup Fanny
guinochet l'édito Eco sur France Info
tous les matins Céline braque odoxa tous
les mois sur les chaînes parlementaires
pour scruter les bienvenue sur l'opinion
et elles amont d'un Gava dlcp à mes
côtés comme chaque soir
et puis très belle soirée documentaire
et puis à demain bien sûr même lui-même
[Musique]